the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video alright
my friends in this video we will have
another look at george rr martin's most
recent interview with house of the
dragons writer and showrunner ryan
condell this new interview not only
shines a light on their working
relationship but it also gives us more
insight into how they went about making
house of the dragon
now as you all know house of the dragon
is hbo's new game of thrones series
based on george rr martin's writing in
fire and blood in house of the dragon we
will see what happened to house
targaryen during the events known as the
dance of the dragons as of right now we
are less than three months away from
finally seeing westeros again now i
don't know about all of you but i'm
getting very excited i have been waiting
for this day for over 3 years now before
i go any further i just want to say i
will be giving away my extra copy of
fire and blood in 30 days i will be
sending this extra book to one of you
all you got to do is subscribe to enter
the giveaway i want to make sure i send
this out before the new show starts this
will give one of you a chance to learn a
lot more information about house
targaryen before house of the dragon
airs its first episode good luck to
those of you who subscribed to enter the
giveaway now let's get back to the video
now that the first episode of house of
the dragon is on the horizon co-creators
george rr martin and ryan condole have
been sitting down for interviews to
discuss their new show when they sat
down with idris elba for the recent
interview they went into some of the
details about how their relationship
started according to george rr martin he
said it all started about three years
ago when hbo knew game of thrones was
ending this was when they knew they
wanted to move forward with a successor
show as you can imagine george rr martin
gave them several different ideas for a
new show and one of those ideas centered
around house targaryen and what happened
during the dance of the dragons when all
of this first started happening he said
hbo already had other writers in mind
some of those writers did not get very
far some of them got considerably far
and did good work but they did
eventually find themselves without a
writer and one day when george met with
ryan condo at the four seasons he
thought hey you would be great for this
not only had ryan read all of his novels
about westeros but according to george
he said ryan knew a lot about fantasy in
general he goes on to say now i have to
admit i'm not the most subjective guy in
this discussion i'm the author of the
original source material when you get a
writer who is hired to do an adaptation
but is not familiar with the original
material in some cases they hire someone
who doesn't even like the original
material and you have this language in
hollywood you will hear some of these
writers say i'm gonna make it my own i
have my own vision for this and that
sort of thing
not even discussing my work but
discussing myself as a viewer as a
consumer of things if i go to see the
great gatsby i don't want someone else's
version on the great gatsby i don't want
them to make it their own i won scott's
fitzgerald brought to life in front of
my face
now unfortunately you don't always get
that so to be able to work with someone
like ryan not just that he knew my books
the fact that he knew fantasy and love
fantasy was a big thing for me now if
this doesn't get you excited then i
don't know what will
according to george r martin it honestly
does sound like ryan will make a very
faithful adaptation it sounds like he's
saying ryan will make it exactly how the
author wanted it to be in fact this is
essentially what ryan says as well
during the same interview ryan said so
for me it was a trust building exercise
and the way miguel and i went into this
was as fans of the original show so what
we're all trying to do is create the
thing that we as fans would want to see
for me as a fan that meant a very
faithful adaptation so i was very lucky
in this case i had george's ear i shared
every outline that i wrote with him for
the first episode and every draft for
the pilot i wrote and then once that
started getting going and hbo was happy
i think george was happy and knew where
the story was heading and how he wanted
to move forward with the rest of the
season so that's what i really try to do
i basically made sure he was getting as
much information as i could then we
eventually wrote a series bible and he
came to los angeles to join us and heard
how all of that was unfolding so i think
at every step of the way he always knew
where the story was going so with me it
was always making sure he was involved
and keeping his eyes on it as much as i
could because i felt like if george
blessed this and said it was good or if
we debated on something and it's not the
thing he wanted we would find a solution
then i felt like i had done my job as
the author of the adaptation we did have
some healthy debates during the early
stages of developing house of the dragon
mostly about how the show would be
structured it involved a deep and
introspective look into how the material
that you wouldn't necessarily have to do
if you were just reading or discussing
it as a history book if you've read fire
and blood then you would know that it's
one guy archmaester gildane having to
sift through three other guys who all
have an incomplete account on the
history of what happened hoping to
figure out what actually happened
because we're telling the objective
version of this story we had to make
decisions about if this was going to
happen and how that was going to happen
alright so as you can see with the
interview it sounds like they are making
as faithful of an adaptation as you can
make given that they are adapting a fake
history book that does have several
different versions of the same events
if you've read fire and blood then you
know it's not structured like george's
other novels and a song of ice and fire
unfortunately fire and blood doesn't
have very much dialogue so that's
something ryan and the other writers
will have to do on their own
not only that but like i said there are
several different accounts on the same
event so they will have to decide on
whose version of these events they will
follow it will be very interesting to
see how all of this will unfold at the
end of the day they have a very good
outline because george rr martin had
already basically established what
happened during a lot of the major
events during the dance of the dragons
he has already laid out who will live
who will die and who will be seated on
the iron throne so we already know it
will have a great ending in the sense
that it won't feel like it has any holes
one thing i do know is we will find out
exactly how good house of the dragon is
in less than three months the day we
have all been waiting for is finally
almost here i have faith that ryan will
deliver a great show it honestly sounds
like that's what he wants to do for the
fans i think he also wants to do this
for george rr martin i don't think he
wants to let him down either he has been
a fan of his for several decades now so
i doubt he wants to do something that
might negatively affect how the fans
will look at his body of work either way
we will see soon enough
as always i want to thank all of you for
watching this video also don't forget to
subscribe if you would like to enter to
win george rr martin's fire and blood
vol 1.
good luck and have a great day i will
see all of you back here very soon for
my next video
bye
[Music]
you